good morning here we are it started the
ftth conference is here at London's XL
center right in the heart of London all
organized of course by the ftth Council
Europe now it's going to be two
incredible days of convention here at
the XL center and of course today is the
10th anniversary of the ftth conference
so brace yourselves everyone here we go
good morning Hardwick now you've been
here since the first FTTH conference
what would you say are the main
differences today compared to the first
event the event today is much different
than the first FTTH conferences in the
last few years that it gained momentum
and became the largest FTTH event in the
world with more than 3,000 participants
already last year the reason is that
people were interested in 502 the home
are not only the engineers but also
municipalities regulators government and
even a new range of stakeholders such as
finance ea's media and film industry and
even the end user
good morning Karen now you are the new
president of the ftth Council Europe
congratulations how does it feel to be
giving the conference's opening speech
in the next few minutes I'm excited of
course the past few years have been
sitting in the audience listening to
other speakers and this year it's my
time so I'm looking forward to that and
I'm one of the believers wefted age and
of course we're here in the UK now
trying to convince more people not only
locally but also in the rest of Europe
so I'm looking forward to this event
good morning Alexander now what message
will you be delivering in your keynote
speech today I will discuss the fact
that we're only the beginning of the
internet revolution and this is so
profound that if we want to invest in
the future and in our children there's
nothing better to invest in them
broadband media creative arts education
and the state rat right now means that
we cannot over invest in these areas
this is the future good morning Nadia
good morning now this event is the 10th
anniversary for the ftth conference what
is the program for today today is very
exciting is the opening session and
ceremony we have high-level speakers
from the European Parliament from the
European Commission and from the shadow
government in the UK which will be
followed by a keynote address by our
keynote speaker Alexander barred by the
internet revolution and then we will
have a big session with big names in the
film and media industry very exciting
morning